romain élémentaire merci d'être avec
nous tout d'abord votre réaction à ce
décès bonsoir plus d'avoir le bonsoir à
vous même mais je vous dirai tout ce que
nous avons appris avec une très grande
tristesse le décès du président idriss
deby itno
en cette période de ramadan au tchad ce
soldat se fier soldat au destin
exceptionnel aura marqué de son
empreinte l'histoire l'histoire
tumultueuse de notre de notre pays
manon hommage à la mémoire de ce grand
homme d'état qui a contribué puissamment
à la stabilité et à la sécurité à la
sécurité internationale donc nous
adressons nos condoléances les plus
émues à ta nation tchadienne tout entier
est ce qu'on en sait davantage matelas
ou terre sur les circonstances de sa
mort parce qu'il y avait quelques
versions qui ont différé ces dernières
heures
bien nous n'avons pas encore de
l'information exacte sur les
circonstances de sa mort mais nous
savons qu'il s'était déplacé
personnellement sur le terrain au milieu
de ses troupes pour faire face aux
forces adverses et qu'il a été donc en
effet à cette occasion
mais je ne saurai vous donner des
détails plus précis pour l'instant
clairement c'est et c'est quelque chose
que vous redoutiez 7
disparition du président tchadien
évidemment c'est une disparition qui
laisse un grand vide
étant donnée la la personnalité du
président idriss deby itno
vous savez que les les institutions de
la ivème république reposer entièrement
sur la personnalité du pays d'ans et
donc du coup sa disparition brusque qui
a surpris plus d'un et qui a surpris
mais tout le monde laisse un grand vide
et en même temps où le terrain de foot
justement c'était la prochaine question
c'est un couvre feu a été décrété les
frontières fermées sont six à assurera
l'intérim avant des élections dont 18
mois est ce qu'on peut clairement
craindre qu'une forte instabilité
s'empare du pays
diagou nous restons toujours optimiste
nous préférons rester optimiste
en faisant appel à la capacité de
dialogue des canadiens à la sérénité de
tout l'ensemble c'est à dire toute la
classe politique et y
les canadiens font preuve de maturité
évidemment cette période complexe qui
s'ouvre pour être surmontées et
maintenant nous avait tant à dieu le
tout puissant tout en gardant la volonté
de dialoguer sérieusement dans le cadre
d'une transition avec l'ensemble de
nature politique
que sait-on justement sur son fils
mamata idriss deby est ce qu'il va
poursuivre en attendant cette transition
sur la même ligne que son père est ce
qu'il pourrait lui succéder durablement
bien c'est à lui de le goût de vous
répondre
pour m
donc la classe politique est devant un
fait accompli beaucoup de discussions
vont certainement s'engager çà et là
pour dessiner l'avenir politique du 4
vous conviendrez avec moi que la
situation extrêmement complexe
bien sûr nous connaissons office et
driss la matrice et débit qui est
général de corps d'armée nous le
connaissons moins attaqué une politique
ce n'est pas une politique
il vient donc de prendre les choses en
main dans le vide et il appartient donc
à tous les cas bien ensemble dans la
concertation de devenir dans la paix et
dans la sécurité
l'avenir de l'autre celle pelli ma
dernière question l'elysée a regretté à
la mort d'un ami courageux on sert le
tchad est un fervent allié de la france
dans la lutte contre le terrorisme
notamment son décès compliquer les
choses pour les forces françaises
oui il était quand même l'un des piliers
l'un des piliers de la politique
sécuritaire internationale au sailhenc
ont voulu vous le savez et sa
disparition que tout de suite donc
inquiéter les partenaires mais là
également nous le restons optimistes
vous savez que le pays d'art et de débit
avec des qualités particulières dans le
domaine donc aux militaires c'était un
soldat et il s'est toujours senti bien
au coeur au milieu de ses amis et je
dirais que c'est surtout aucun aucun la
côte et de ses amis de ses compagnons
d'armes qui l'a toujours ont trouvé sa
raison d'être est malheureusement son
destin et la loire
cela merci merci mahamat à la hauteur
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur arte
france pour évoquer le décès l'idri déby
au tchad merci à vous